bonjour à tous alors n'étant pas
insulaire puisque je suis sénatrice de
la Guyane donc qui est qui est sur un
continent sud-américain la population
guyanaise se trouve confrontée au même
problématique que la Martinique qui vous
a parlé de ben déjà de l'offre de soins
qui est plutôt bancal chez nous puisque
bien souvent on évacue vers la
Martinique et donc ça veut dire que
quand même la Martinique Catherine vous
êtes un peu en avance quand même sur
nous dans ce domaine et moi je vais je
vais distinguer la continuité
territoriale par rapport au vol
transatlantique alors la Martinique à
trois compagnies nous nous disposons de
deux Air France et Air Caraïbes avec des
coûts de billets en économie à 1200
euros donc mettez-vous à la place des
Guyanais qui veulent se déplacer aussi
bien pour étudier que pour se soigner et
puis dire que on parle de continuité
territoriale aussi dans l'intérieur
puisque la Guyane à des territoires des
communes qui ne sont accessibles que par
avion donc il y a erguyan mais alors que
c'est plutôt c'est très cas autant parce
que souvent les avions s'entendent
souvent il y a des problèmes par rapport
à la climatologie donc les habitants par
exemple de marie-pasoula de papaye tant
de grands sentis sont souvent bloqués
chez eux alors vous imaginez quand on
parle de continuité territoriale on
parle d'économie aussi comme vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure du du coût de des
matières premières et donc voilà alors
nous c'était surtout pour partager puis
prendre vos expériences puisque nous on
est encore pire que la Martinique que
Saint-Martin que Saint-Barth que sa
Pierre et Miquelon nous sommes vraiment
les dernières roues du carrosse et je
vous assure que la population guyanaise
commence à déjà révolté mais de plus en
plus parce que on voit ce qui se passe
autour de nous et nous sommes bloqués
nous sommes encore on va dire entre
guillemets à terme on est là on peut pas
voler on peut rien faire et c'est
compliqué pour nous voilà ce que je
voulais dire je vais vous faire partager
en tout cas les difficultés de la Guyane